everybody thinks they're a loser every
young person thinks they're a loser at
least a young person in the situation I
was at I didn't know I wasn't a loser
until I started winning until I started
doing martial arts martial arts taught
me that like I could get better at stuff
that I wasn't really a loser I just was
someone who was like in a [__] up
situation but you could Channel all that
energy that you have as a young person
into something and get better at it and
then all sudden people admired me I was
like this is crazy so I went from being
someone who was incredibly insecure to
someone who was really successful at
this one thing that was very dangerous
that other people were scared of and
that gave me immense confidence and also
a real understanding of the direct
correlation between hard work and
success